[Music]
developing now from the i-team a missing
young woman's remains found where teams
had searched for months now her family's
left with even more questions the
i-team's david charn is here now with
their message and also a plea for your
help tonight david denise we first
showed you this video earlier this year
you can see 26 year old jawahar hedgie
walking alone right near a construction
site in henderson we now know this is
the last moment she's seen alive
it's the final moments jawahar hedgie
was known to be alive a camera capturing
the 26 year old walking alone near a
construction site at the base of black
mountain in henderson 10 months later on
wednesday police confirming skeletal
remains found on the mountain last month
are hedgies but they don't know yet how
she died to me it doesn't seem right
that
she was found where we were looking i
feel like somebody did something and
bought her back
but it's like so many different
scenarios that we don't know what
happened jawahar's family telling the
i-team a climber found her remains in an
area that's difficult for anybody to
access her sister telling the i-team in
march that jawahar had parked her car at
the construction site just steps from
the amargosa trail several searches over
several months turned up nothing and
they were saying that
she was found in a place that
it was hard to find but how come you
know the canine dogs didn't go search
down there
it just doesn't make sense we don't know
juwaher's family also telling the i-team
in march that she had sat in her car for
two hours before getting out and walking
off the family says she had put her car
keys on her roof and just walked away
all her belongings were left inside
including her phone which was wiped of
all messages
the searches involved boots on the
ground drones even helicopters with no
signs of her and investigators don't
even know how she died yet tonight her
family continues to ask you for any
information if you were on that trail
that december day may have seen
something in the months previous months
to come forward denis